♪♪
Narrator: ADAM, ALLIE, ELIJAH,
AND CANNAN HAVE HIT THE ROAD
TO FIND A SUITABLE LOCATION FOR
A FLATUS-FUELED ROCKET LAUNCH.
THAT'S NOT A SENTENCE
YOU HEAR EVERY DAY.
Adam: I AM CURRENTLY STANDING
AT THE SOUTHEASTERN END
OF SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AT THE TRI-CITIES LANDFILL.
WE HAVE HAD MANY SHENANIGANS
ON THE PROPERTIES
OF WASTE MANAGEMENT.
WE'VE LAUNCHED
DUCT-TAPE TREBUCHETS...
Narrator: YEP. ADAM AND JAMIE
PROVED THEIR FAVORITE MATERIAL
IS PRETTY HANDY IF YOU EVER NEED
TO SLING A FLAMING PROJECTILE
AT AN INFLATABLE
GREAT WHITE SHARK.
YEAH!
WE HIT IT!
IT'S BURNING!
WE'VE EVEN SET FIRES
IN FAKE KITCHENS
AND DOUSED THEM
WITH HELICOPTERS FULL OF WATER.
Jamie:
GRANNY'S ON FIRE, TOO.
Narrator:
THAT EXCURSION BUSTED THE MYTH
THAT BY DOUSING A KITCHEN
GREASE FIRE WITH WATER --
A CHOPPER-LOAD
FOR MYTHBUSTERY GOOD MEASURE --
DOES NOT CREATE A FIREBALL.
NO FIRE!
FIRE GONE!
TODAY, WE ARE LAUNCHING ROCKETS
USING ONLY MY FARTS.
WHAT COULD BE BETTER?!
LET'S GET TO IT.
THIS MYTH IS ALL ABOUT TESTING
IF ADAM'S FARTS
ARE A VIABLE COMBUSTIBLE FUEL.
I WOULD SAY IF WE GET A GOOD
LIFTOFF FROM THAT ROCKET,
HIS FARTS
ARE LOOKING PRETTY GOOD.
Narrator:
THE RIP-ONE ROCKET IS READY.
IT'S BEEN GIVEN AN AERODYNAMIC
MAKEOVER BY ELIJAH AND CANNAN
AND HAS THE ALL-IMPORTANT NOZZLE
FOR EFFICIENT THRUST.
Adam:
ALLIE HAD SOME AMAZING RESULTS
EXPERIMENTING WITH DIFFERENT
RATIOS OF OXYGEN TO FART GAS,
AND WE'RE TESTING WITH HER
BEST RATIO FROM THE PARKING LOT.
Narrator: AND THAT VITAL
STOICHIOMETRY IS 60% ADAM...
ADDING FART GAS NOW.
...TO 40% OXYGEN.
YOU KNOW, AFTER THIS,
ALLIE, YOU CAN TELL PEOPLE
THAT YOU'RE AN AMATEUR
ROCKET SCIENTIST.
-OKAY.
-[ LAUGHS ]
-SOUNDS GOOD.
-LET'S SEE.
ALL RIGHT.
THERE WE GO.
LET'S GO.
-LET'S GO.
Narrator: THE FLATUS FLIGHT CREW
TOUCH BASE WITH LAUNCH CONTROL.
ALL RIGHT.
HERE.
WILL YOU RADIO BACK TO BASE CAMP
FOR AN IGNITION CHECK?
-Rocket stand to base camp.
-COPY.
YES, COULD WE GET
AN IGNITION CHECK, PLEASE?
YES, YOU CAN.
THANK YOU.
IGNITION CHECK IN 3...
2...1.
[ ELECTRICITY CRACKLES ]
PERFECT!
Narrator:
AND THE FULLY LOADED ROCKET
IS SET INTO THE GANTRY.
THIS ROCKET LOOKS
AMAZING.
Allie: SO FAR, IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE GOING TO GET LIFTOFF,
SO HOLD ON TO YOUR BUTTS.
ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE LOCKED AND LOADED.
YOU GUYS READY?
-YEAH.
I CAN'T WAIT FOR THIS
TO HOPEFULLY HAVE LIFTOFF.
Adam: WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU THINK IT'S GONNA WORK?
Cannan: I THINK THIS MIGHT HAVE
A CHANCE AT POSSIBLY WORKING.
Adam:
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
I HAVE NO CLUE
WHAT'S GONNA HAPPEN,
BUT IT'S GONNA BE GOOD.
THAT'S HEDGING YOUR BETS
LIKE A HYNEMAN.
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT, ELIJAH,
COUNT IT IN.
ALL RIGHT. FULL-SCALE
FART-ROCKET TEST IN 3...
2...1.
[ CHEERS AND LAUGHTER ]
THAT WENT SO HIGH!
AH-HA-HA-HA-HA-HA-HA!
-THAT WAS AMAZING!
-WHOO! THAT WAS AWESOME!
YAY!
♪♪
AMAZING. AH!
WOW.
THAT WENT TO, LIKE,
30 OR 40 FEET, I THINK.
THAT'S CRAZY.
IT ALSO STAYED ON
THE BALLISTIC TRAJECTORY,
WENT "DOOOOOOO!
DOOP."
Cannan: OUR ROCKET WENT
34 FEET INTO THE AIR
AND TRAVELED
AT 38 MILES PER HOUR.
IT SHOT WAY HIGHER THAN
I COULD HAVE EVER IMAGINED,
AND IT WAS JUST
THE WEIRDEST THING
TO THINK THAT
IT WAS POWERED BY FLATULENCE.
ADAM, YOUR FARTS
BLEW ME AWAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]